Great. Welcome everybody. It's my great pleasure to chair this
session, this major symposium on targeting programmed cell death.
We are really excited to have you all here.
This is actually a really exciting time for this field, and we think that there's a
lot of opportunities here going beyond just the
initial forms of cell death that we've known about for a long time, such
as apoptosis, but down the road, targeting other alternate forms of
cell death, such as ferroptosis. And today, we're going to be talking a little bit
about some of those opportunities.
So we're glad to have you here.
So I wanted to provide just a little bit of context before we get started.
And as I've mentioned, there's several different forms of programmed
cell death that have now been identified, including apoptosis, ferroptosis,
necroptosis, pyroptosis. In fact, there's probably a new form of cell
death described just about every month in the literature.
And I think this opens up a lot of really exciting opportunities going forward
to not only understand which forms of cell death are targetable
and potentially can lead to more effective therapies for cancer
patients, but also identifying where these forms of cell death
actually interface. Where is the crosstalk between them?
And how can we push cells from one form of cell death to another to
potentially elicit anti-cancer immune responses or other
more effective treatments?
Importantly, when we talk about the time that it takes to actually
target programmed cell death in the clinic, this can be a multi-decades
endeavor. And I'm showing you here how long it's been since we've actually
discovered that BCL2 has oncogenic properties.
This was first done in 1988. All the way through, it took about 20
years to come up with the first drugs targeting
BCL2 that had clinical activity and were found to be
safe.
And that led to the 2016 FDA approval for
venetoclax, ABT-199, which now has been
utilized in scores of patients to be highly effective at
controlling CLL, AML, and other heme malignancies.
However, we are further behind with some of our other
proteins that we're trying to target, especially in the BCL2 family.
So here I'm showing you a quick overview of some of the key pro-survival proteins
that we know are potentially targetable in apoptosis.
So BCL2, we already have a drug, and actually several other additional drugs that
have been FDA approved to target this protein.
Extremely effective at controlling several different heme malignancies,
including CLL, AML, few other hematologic malignancies.
However, we are much further behind when it comes to targeting some of these other
key pro-survival proteins, including BCLXL and MCL1,
which have been hampered by some on-target and some poorly understood,
in certain cases, toxicities. Interestingly, we are
standing now at a time in the field where we are starting to understand those
toxicities much more effectively and we're able to overwhelm or
overcome them through some innovative drug engineering.
And we'll hear about some of that here today.
I wanted to just leave with a quick slide showing you what are the key
areas of focus for this field of targeting apoptosis that will then
apply also to the targeting of alternate cell death pathways in the
future.
So step one in this field was really developing selective potent
inhibitors of pro-survival proteins.
These are the anti-apoptotic proteins that cancer cells rely upon to
survive. I feel like we've
mostly completed that task. We have very good inhibitors of the major
pro-survival proteins. We also have done a great job of
identifying which cancers might be sensitive to single agent
treatment with these inhibitors.
Where we still are lacking is the remaining steps here, which includes
combination treatments that are able to
leverage targeted therapies and other
lineage-based vulnerabilities in combination with BH3 mimetics
to drive enhanced cancer cell death.
We also need to learn more about how we can potentially get the right
drugs to the right patients. So even within a cancer type where we know that
there's high BCL2 dependence in CLL, for example, how do we know which
patients are going to respond most favorably?
It's actually a big interest of our current NCI director, Anthony
Letai, who's pioneered the use of BH3 profiling for that
type of answer. We also need
to help ensure that our pro-survival protein inhibitors, such as
inhibitors of BCLXL and MCL1, are adequately tolerated.
We know that there are some toxicities there, and we really need to understand them
better and find clever ways to get around that.
And finally, we need to understand where are the limitations,
such as solid tumors. Targeting them with BH3 mimetics has
been more difficult due to their inherent resistance to apoptotic cell
death. How do we potentially overcome that?
And also in heme malignancies, as we'll hear today from Andreas and also
from Larry Boyse, there's high rates of development of
resistance to some of these agents.
And so we need to better understand what are those modes of resistance development
and how we can also evade those. So with that, I'm very
excited to turn over the podium to our first speaker, Andreas Strasser from the
Walter and Eliza Hall Institute. He'll be telling us about enhancing the activity
of BH3 mimetics. Let's welcome him to the podium.
Thank you very much, Chris. Thank you very much
to everyone for coming.
So here's my disclosures. I'd like you to
note them, especially the first two or three.
As Chris already introduced, this is the apoptotic
pathway as we know it today. The cell death pathway that is probably best
studied,
and it's regulated or executed by the
pro-apoptotic proteins Bax and Bak.In healthy cells,
these proteins are kept in check by the pro-survival proteins like
BCL2 and MCL1, BCLXL.
And cells commit to death when the BH3-only proteins
are increased in response to stresses such as chemotherapeutic
drugs.
This happens through transcriptional or post-transcriptional processes.
The BH3-only proteins bind with very high affinity to the pro-survival
proteins, and that liberates Bax and Bak to kill the cells.
Some BH3-only proteins have also been reported to be able to activate
Bax and Bak directly.
Because of the knowledge of this pathway, as Chris mentioned,
BH3 mimetic drugs have been developed with
the BCL2 inhibitor venetoclax, the one that is approved and
used regularly in the clinic.
The challenge with BH3 mimetic drugs, as
we see it come for all of them, and certainly is already the case for venetoclax,
is emergence of resistance to BCL2
inhibition. This shows the survival of CLL
patients, as published by Andrew Roberts from our institute
a few years ago.
So
our groups at WEHI and many groups around the world have been
studying mechanisms of resistance by studying patients,
or we have done CRISPR gene knockout and gene activation
screens in cells. And
what came up was, to me, the most surprising thing was point
mutations in BCL2. I would have predicted any mutation in
BCL2 that affects binding of venetoclax will also
abrogate its binding of the BH3-only proteins and therefore make it a null
protein. Well,
nature is different than what I think.
Upregulation of the untargeted proteins was seen very regularly in
our CRISPR gene activation screens and also in
resistant samples in patients. Loss of Bax we found as
a top hit in our genetic screens. It's also been
seen not very frequently in patients.
The biggest surprise for us was our biggest hit in our genetic screens and
knockouts was p53. And
we thought, "Well, that makes no sense at all." The BH3
mimetics were made in part precisely because they work
downstream of p53. p53 is one of the
transcriptional activators of the BH3-only proteins like Bim and
Puma and Noxa. So how can a mutation in
p53 affect this pathway?
And we were really puzzled, but then pretty much at that
time when we got these genetic screen data,
these data came out from patient cohorts, and that is
loss of p53 in CLL portends poorer survival,
and in AML, mutations in p53 portend
absolutely dismal prognosis. So that meant
what we found in the lab probably does matter, and we should find out
how p53 influences the response to BH3
mimetic drugs.
Sarah Diepstra, a postdoc with Jemah Kelly, then did
an experiment that I told her you should never do because it's entirely stupid,
and that was to look whether when you treat cells with a BH3
mimetic drug, in this case, these are our workhorse Miklin lymphoma
lines, which are highly dependent on MCL1, so she treated with an
MCL1 inhibitor, but she's seen the same in BCL2
sensitive cells with venetoclax treatment.
There is an increase in p53 protein, suggesting that
maybe p53 becomes activated.
And as I said before, this is also seen in human
lymphoma cells, not just in mouse lymphomas.
Not only is p53 stabilized and therefore
putatively activated, it is actually activated because when
we did RNA-seq analysis of BH3 mimetic
drug-treated lymphoma cells, one of the top pathways that was
upregulated is the p53 signaling pathway.
And here is just an example of some of the classical
p53 target genes that are clearly activated in these
lymphoma cells when they're treated with an IC50 or
IC75 or IC90 of this MCL1
inhibitor. Noxa, Puma, Bim, p21, all these
classical target genes are highly upregulated.
So
that then made us wonder whether
perhaps when mitochondrial outer membrane
permeabilization is induced, maybe sufficiently to
kill the cells or maybe even more importantly, kind of on the
borderline when some cells might actually be able to survive that
treatment,
mOMP somehow leads to p53 activation,
perhaps through release of mitochondrial DNA, a
process that was studied by Ben Kyle many years ago, who's
sitting over there.
Indeed, that was the case because when Sarah made Bax/Bak
double knockout variant of these lymphoma cells, which are
shown on the right here, when these cells are treated with the MCL1
inhibitor, there's no more increase in p53.
Oops.
And
this is not because p53 cannot be activated in these cells, because when
they're treated with the MDM2 inhibitor nutlin, p53
levels go up dramatically.
And also,
the removal of Bax and Bak actually
completely abolished the induction of Puma, Noxa,
and Bim after treatment with a BH3 mimetic drug.
So this
process is clearly dependent on
mOMP.So
this is
our hypothesis that we then had, and that is that p53 may
function not only as an inducer of apoptosis by
transcriptional induction of the proapoptotic BH3-only genes,
but that's also as an enforcer. So perhaps in
cells that are kind of off the brink of whether they die or will not die,
MAMP, through release of
mitochondrial DNA, can then activate p53
in a way to amplify apoptosis signaling to get more
p53 activity. Exactly how MAMP activates
p53, we haven't actually worked out.
In leukemia cells that would be p53 deficient or
mutant, this amplification loop will not happen,
so some tumor cells may survive, and that may be the seed for
disease relapse that is seen in venetoclax plus
azacitidine-treated AML or in venetoclax plus
a CD20 antibody-treated
CLL.
So one thing that we also noted when we were doing these
experiments is that
the induction of BIM, NOXA, and
PUMA was actually reduced by knocking out p53, but
it wasn't absolutely abrogated. There was still a way to
upregulate it. And we thought this could be very interesting.
We would like to know what the mechanism of that is, and if we understand
that mechanism, then maybe if that could be activated
pharmacologically, then this could be a way to boost
the effects of BH3 mimetic drugs in the clinic.
So the
RNA-seq analysis that I showed you the data already actually
provided an excellent clue to what the mechanism was.
So the top hit
in the RNA-seq was not actually the p53 pathway.
The top hit was interferon alpha response,
and that immediately made us think of cGAS-STING
signaling. So this pathway is activated
in response to cytosolic DNA, for example, viral
DNA or mitochondrially released DNA, as
discovered by Flavell and Ben Kyle and their groups many years ago.
This leads to the activation of STING, which then activates
TBK1. TBK1 can activate
IRF3. And quite interestingly, it was
already shown that IRF3 may be able to activate
transcription of BIM. So we thought, well, maybe this is
actually the pathway we should be studying.
Indeed, in these lymphoma cells and many other
leukemia and lymphoma cells of mouse and human origin,
when we treat them with BH3 mimetic drugs, STING is
activated, TBK1 is activated, IRF3
is activated. And this is entirely
independent of p53 because it's still seen in the
p53 knockout derivatives of these lymphoma cells.
And correspondingly to that, when you knockout
STING,
these cells, when they're treated with an MCL-1 inhibitor, there's less
induction of NOXA or PUMA and BIM. It's not abrogated
similarly to what we saw with the p53 knockout in the same lymphoma
cells. Of note, when you do a double knockout of
p53 and STING, their induction is almost entirely
abrogated, indicating that it's really these two
pathways that drive this feed-forward loop, one
activation of p53, the other one activation of the
cGAS-STING pathway.
So with these data in hand, we thought, well, maybe we could actually
exploit this knowledge. Maybe
if we combine
STING agonists with a BH3 mimetic drug, maybe we'll get much more
bang for our buck than with either agent
alone, with the hope that maybe this would also
be possible then to use with BH3 mimetic drugs that at the
moment, as Chris mentioned, are progressing relatively slowly in the clinic
because of their on-target toxicity.
Maybe this will allow us to reduce their
concentrations.
So this is the STING agonist that we worked with.
They are all highly potent.
STING agonists were originally
developed by several pharma companies, not with the aim to
induce apoptosis in an intrinsic manner in cells as
we discovered, but actually by
stimulating the immune system, hoping that this would further
boost the immune
activation effects of PD-1 or PD-L1 or CDL4
inhibitors. The good news about the work that was done on these STING
agonists is that they are safe in patients.
The bad news is that in boosting cancer immunotherapy,
the signal hasn't been very strong.
So first thing we did is to see whether STING agonists on their own
can actually kill leukemia and lymphoma cells, and
indeed they can. So this is a group of MCL lymphoma
cells. This is the levels of STING that is found in these cells.
It's not super high, but it's present.
And very interestingly, the potency of the STING agonist is
directly correlated to the amount of STING found in these lymphoma
cells. So this cell here that has relatively little
STING is the most resistant. This that has the most is the most
sensitive one. Knockout of p53
provides some protection, but not far from complete
protection.We then
did the control experiment to show that the STING
agonists, as they're supposed to do, they activate
TBK1, they activate IRF3, and
this activation is entirely independent of
p53. It doesn't require MOMP either, because a
Bax-Bak double knockout cell, the STING agonist still activates
IRF3, still induces massive levels of BIM,
and also substantial levels of Puma.
The antibodies to PumaHCH is not very good, so that's why the signal is
not that strong.
The killing of these lymphoma cells, as you would predict, is entirely
dependent on IRF3, because when Sarah knocked
out IRF3, the killing of these cells was pretty
much abrogated.
So that means the pathway that is engaged by the STING agonist
is STING activating TBK1 and IRF3,
and that induces Noxa, Puma, and BIM.
The NF-kappaB activation pathway,
I haven't shown you the data, but is not required for cell killing.
The next thing that Sarah did is to see whether the killing of
cells by STING agonists is entirely apoptosis
or whether other cell death pathways may also play a role.
It is entirely apoptosis because Bax-Bak double knockout cells
are entirely resistant to STING agonist treatment, and the
killing is actually pretty much accounted for by the transcriptional
induction of Noxa, Puma, and BIM, because these triple knockouts
are almost as resistant as the Bax-Bak double knockouts.
Maybe there's another BH3-only protein that plays a role as well.
The next thing that we did is to check whether the
STING agonists can actually boost the killing of lymphoma and
leukemia cells induced by BH3 mimetic drugs,
and indeed it can. So this is the killing you get with
an MCL-1 inhibitor. This is the killing you get with
a STING agonist, and this is the killing that you get in the
combination treatment.
This is entirely unaffected by p53 knockout, and
it's entirely apoptotic cell death because the Bax-Bak double knockout cells are
completely resistant to that killing.
So the next step was to go in
vivo and see whether the STING agonists can
provide a protective effect. So
this is experiments-- The first experiments we did was in Rag
knockout mice, because our lymphoma cells have Cas9
in them, which is highly immunogenic.
So if you put them into a wild-type mouse, they just get immune
rejected.
So this is the protective effect you get with the STING
agonist. This is the protective effect you get with the
MCL-1 inhibitor, and you get a much greater protection.
About 50% of mice actually survive with the dual treatment.
If the cancer cells are p53 knockout,
there's still a high protective effect of the dual treatment, but it
is diminished. Now, please remember that curve here.
So this is the survival that we see in immune deficient
mice, in Rag knockout mice.
The next experiment that Sarah did
was to actually do it in mice with a competent immune system.
So for that, we just took Cas9 transgenic mice, which are
immunologically tolerant to Cas9, so the lymphoma cells don't
get rejected by the immune system.
And what you can see here is that
even when the lymphoma cells are knockout for p53, the STING
agonist alone gives phenomenal extension of
lifespan. So a mouse with a MIC lymphoma that lives at 100 days
will live at 300 days. They're essentially cured,
and the combination with the BH3 mimetic drug gave even greater
protection.
So moving on from that,
we were wondering which other hematological cancers or
solid cancers could be candidates for such a
combination treatment. So
these are
looking at published data, RNA-seq published data sets.
And when you look at acute myeloid leukemia, they have very high
levels of STING. This is the levels of STING across
non-Hodgkin's lymphoma. Some subtypes have very high levels of
STING, but many actually are very, very low.
So a lot of
B-cell lymphomas in humans, for example, are actually quite low
for STING or don't have detectable STING levels, so you'd
predict they would not respond to a STING agonist.
So this is in vitro experiments with AML patient samples.
The red ones are from p53 mutant relapsed
AML. And when they're treated with the STING agonist,
all of them are potently killed with the exception of this one.
And in most of these AML samples in vitro,
the combination of venetoclax plus the STING agonist gives
substantially more killing than either agent alone.
So the final data that I'll show you is this one here.
So this is an experiment with a human AML
PDX in NSG-SGG3 mice.
And the single agent treatment with a STING agonist
gives very marked protection. Combining it-- and this
is a venetoclax-resistant disease, adding
venetoclax adds some survival advantage.
But most importantly, when you look at the leukemic burden
by intramedullary biopsy, there's another one and a half
log drop in leukemic cells in the dual combination of
venetoclax plus the
STING agonist compared to the STING agonist
alone.So in summary,
we believe that p53 not only triggers cell death
by apoptosis, but it can also enforce it through this
amplification loop.
We also believe that STING agonists can induce proapoptotic
BH3-only proteins transcriptionally, and this is in a
p53-independent manner, but IRF-3-dependent
manner.
And
we believe that this tumor cell intrinsic effect of the STING
agonists can actually be further boosted when the
immune system in a human patient is competent,
presumably by activating tumor-specific T cells,
getting more bang for the buck.
And our hope is that combining BH3 mimetic drugs with STING
agonists may be going forward into
clinical assessments. And
indeed,
there is a clinical trial that is being ramped up in Melbourne,
run by Andrew Wei and Andrew Roberts, across many
centers, including the Royal Melbourne Hospital, Peter Mac,
the O&J, and
it's
just recruiting at the moment.
Our research questions is how can we increase STING expression in cancer
cells that actually have very low levels of STING,
and we have made quite a bit of advance on that, and we think that
could be quite interesting.
And finally, we believe that the STING pathway may be
just only one pathway to boost the expression of BIM,
PUMA, and other BH3-only proteins, which could be harnessed to
get more bang for buck out of BH3 mimetic drugs.
And we have done and are doing this by having made transcriptional
reporters for BIM and PUMA, and we've done
CRISPR knockout and CRISPR gene activation screens.
And, in fact, one of our hits was STING, which was really
gratifying. But we have new hits that we're really interested in
working with. So,
I'd like to thank
Sulios, with whom we've done this work with the STING agonists, and this
work was run by Gemma Kelly, who I work
very closely with, by Sarah, and by Eddie
Lamarkat. And I'm very happy to answer questions.
Thank you very much.
If there are questions, please come up to the microphones. David.
Hi, Andreas. Great talk.
In your AML samples, have you looked at some of the
markers on the cells?
I'm wondering if this is really going
on in the CD34 high, CD45 low
population,
which are super hard to maintain in vitro.
You mean
the phenotype of the tumors, or whether CD34 high
normal bone marrow cells are affected by this combination?
No. Whether the AML cells that are CD34 high,
CD45 low exhibit the same behavior with the STING
agonist.
So
some of the samples were of that phenotype.
They were a minority of it, and I showed you just some data.
So Yin Yuan and Andrew Wei and Andrew Roberts have done many,
many more of these samples. They do respond as well.
Some of them even quite good responses, single agent STING
agonist treatment.
The question you didn't answer is, but they did control for
toxicity to normal human stem cells, and this
single treatment with STING agonists or even the dual treatment is
not killing these cells, at least in vitro.
Thanks.
Hi, David Kirsch, Princess Margaret Cancer Center. Great presentation.
I'm wondering about the on-target toxicity of low
platelets and the cardiac injury that's been seen in
clinical trials with some of the drugs, whether that could
be p53 mediated.
Just thinking, if you have
the MDM2 inhibitors also have thrombocytopenia as a toxicity,
because you've got more p53 in specific progenitor cells.
It's a very interesting idea.
I'm not aware that anybody has tested that.
So we have never
treated p53 knockout mice with an MDM2 or
BCL-xL inhibitor, but that could be done very
easily.
My prediction,
certainly for the platelet toxicity, would be that it's not p53
dependent, because it can be completely abrogated
by a
knockout of Bak,
which was shown by David Wang and others.
It can also be
almost completely abrogated by a double knockout of Bad and
BIM.
Mm-hmm.
So it is dependent on
probably p53 independent activation of apoptosis, mostly
by taking BCL-xL's protective
activity out of the game, and then the BH3-only proteins that are
there are sufficient to inhibit whatever other
pro-survival protein happens to be expressed in platelets, which is
actually mostly Mcl-1.
Thank you.
Hi. Really great talk. I'm Victoria Delgazzo Moore
at High Point School of Pharmacy. I was wondering, you said
that it was one-to-one agonist of STING with
venetoclax, and whether that was co-administered or whether that was
in sequence. And then my second question is
whether you've done other ratios or seen how low you
can go with either of the drugs.
Second question is that's being done right now, so we're playing around
with the doses.
The experiment that I showed you, the administration
of the MCL-1 inhibitor, which is what we use for the MCL
lymphomas,
and the STING agonist, they were
spaced apart.
But we have done also experiment where they were administered on the same day.
The way we chose the dosing schedule was mostly
out of
convenience of
who and how many times you had to get up in the middle of the night to treat your
mice. So
it was a convenience schedule rather than a
medically informed schedule.
Right. And was it just one treatment, or was it a
series of treatments over-
No, a series of treatments. Absolutely.
Yeah. Okay. Thank you.
Hi. Great talk. I have a question about the
toxicity of STING agonist in combination with BH3
mimetic on
normal immune cell populations in T cells and other normal myeloid
cells. Do you see killing of these normal cells?
So yeah, we've done quite a bit of work on that.
So the BCL2 inhibitor is actually
quite well-tolerated by cells of the immune system that there is--
and it's seen in patients as well. There is a drop in
neutrophils, but it's not dangerous to the patient.
There's a minor drop in mature T cells, but it's
very minor. And in mice, we still can have
highly functional immune responses to viral infections, so it's not
dose limiting.
MCL-1 inhibitor is actually remarkably
well-tolerated by cells of the immune system
at doses that we can cure mice of lymphoma.
The only thing we see is a 10% drop in B cells, which
is not very much, and B cells can very easily be
recovered. So MCL-1 inhibitor, the
problem is not in the immune system.
It's a cardiac toxicity, and
we found many other toxicities that I'm happy to talk about.
And the BCL-xL inhibitor is actually also quite
well-tolerated in the immune system, with the very
notable exception of the massive platelet
drop. But B cells and T cells are not really affected very much.
Okay. And does STING agonist exacerbate this
toxicity?
So with the MCL-1 inhibitor, no, it does not.
With the venetoclax also doesn't do that.
We haven't combined
the STING agonist with a BCL-xL inhibitor in mice with an immune
system. We've done experiments in xenografts with human
T cell lymphomas, where that combination is actually highly potent.
But these mice don't have an immune system, so I can't really say anything about
that. We haven't done it in mice yet.
Okay. Thank you.
Sorry.
We'll try to make this one kind of quick.
Okay. It's a great presentation. So I was wondering, after you treat
cells or tumor cells with the STING agonist, have you looked at
it whether there is any upregulation of the death receptors on
the surface, on the upper level, membrane level?
We haven't done it at the protein level, but in the RNA-Seq that we have
done that I haven't shown you, with the STING agonist, we haven't seen it.
But we should look at the levels of
trail receptors-
Protein
... FAS and TNF related receptor one. We haven't done it, no.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Good. Thank you.
Great. So now we'll welcome Larry Boyes to the podium.
He's going to be talking about intrinsic and extrinsic factors driving the
targeting of apoptosis.
Thank you, Chris. And again, thank you
for the organizers for allowing us to have this major symposium and
for Chris to put it together. So
I guess before I get started,
I
have disclosures, too, but not nearly as cool as Andreas' were.
And I also want to start actually by thanking people from my lab.
I'll try to mention them along the way, past and present people, as
well as our team. I'm going to talk not about lymphoma or
leukemia, as Andreas did. I'm going to talk mostly about, actually all about
multiple myeloma here,
and thinking about some of the questions that we've been asking.
And so our myeloma team's been very important for this,
and other collaborators
across the continent,
and actually into Europe, too, now that I look at the list.
Our funding, and of course, we use a lot of patient samples for this work, and so I
want to thank our patients and their families as well to get started.
And so
about really 20 years ago, we started thinking about myeloma as
maybe a little bit of a different disease in the fact that the drugs we were
using for them were targeting things that are found in every cell, like
proteasome inhibitors. So it suggested there were functional dependencies
in myeloma that may not be related to what was actually driving the disease.
And we were able to finally show this after almost
20 years in a collaboration with Constantine Mitsiades at the Dana-Farber
Cancer Institute, where we looked at
using the DepMap data, preferential dependencies in myeloma,
a plasma cell malignancy of the bone marrow,
that weren't found in any other of the types of cells in the DepMap
database. And we found 116 of these genes.
And I guess what was remarkable about...
about those 116 genes was that none of them were actually
oncogenes. If you go back into these cells, or if you actually look into large
data sets of which we did that had mutation and
gene expression data on 1,000 newly diagnosed myeloma patients, you just don't see
mutations in these genes. A gain of them
or activating type or mutations.
So what do you see? And this talks a little bit about what the
types of genes these are. So a lot of them are transcriptional regulators,
and many of them are actually essential transcription factors for plasma
cell
differentiation and
maintenance. You see a lot shown here in green of things
associated with protein folding because these are antibody-secreting cells, and so
if you muck up that, the cells do not tolerate it, and that's probably why
proteasome inhibitors, or at least these cells are very sensitive to proteasome
inhibitors. And there's other things in here that are also consistent with cell of
origin plasma cell phenotypes. And one of those included
mitochondrial regulators of apoptosis.
And so we've been actually looking at all of these
areas over the last
decade or so. But I'm really just going to focus on that last one about regulation
of cell death. And one of the early studies that we had done
on this was with Brian Gaudette, a former graduate student.
And he just took data from normal plasma cells,
gene expression data from normal plasma cells, from myeloma plasma cells, or from
another plasma cell dyscrasia called Waldenstrom macroglobulinemia, and
asked what are the differences in expression of the BCL2 families, and these are
using these old data sets. And the only one that he actually found that was
really different between normal plasma cells
in light blue and myeloma cells in dark blue was
BCL2L11. And you should all know what this is now because
Andreas was talking about that a lot.
It's the gene that encodes BIM. And that seems a little bit
backwards to think of a cell acquiring resistance to
cell death, and the one gene we see upregulated is a pro-apoptotic gene.
But it really is consistent with why cells have to evade cell death because
oncogenic stress actually is pro-apoptotic, and we've known
that for some time. And what that results in is this
concept of mitochondrial priming, such that
anti-apoptotic proteins like Mcl1, Bcl-x, and BCL2
have to sequester these pro-apoptotic proteins that are being made due to
the chronic oncogenic stress the cell goes through during the
transformation process for that cell to live, and that's what they have to evade
it. But that actually comes with a consequence.
And now it tends to lower the apoptotic threshold so that if you give another
signal
such as therapy, it can activate the BH3 proteins as Andreas
discussed which could cause the release of BIM and
activate BAX and BAK and cause cytochrome C release.
Where in normal cells, we just don't have that level of mitochondrial priming or in
drug-resistant cells, and you don't get the cytochrome C release.
And so
we've been studying this for some time, but even not only we were, but
actually Chris was, and when he was a postdoc, he did this beautiful study, which I
hope he's not showing in his talk.
Good. And that looking in myeloma and showed that
the level of priming correlated in patients with the
response to therapy shown here, and it didn't matter what the therapy
was. The more priming you had, the more likely the patient was
going to respond, and the outcomes were better in the patients
that had a higher overall priming.
And so we've really spent a lot of our time thinking about
how does this work. And one of the things we found was
that in patient samples, in cell lines, and
everything we were looking at,
nearly all myelomas were Mcl1 dependent.
And we see that.
We do see that we get also
what I'll call BCL2 agonists here.
They can be BH3 mimetics, or they could be PROTACs.
That some cells, while Mcl1 dependent, are also
codependent on BCL2 or Bcl-x, and we can use those things in
combination. However, sometimes we see that BCL2 and Bcl-x are
there and
bound to BIM.
But when you release them, you don't kill the cell because all the BIM moves
over to free Mcl1. That gets
stabilized by that binding. And so what I'm going to go
through really for the rest of the talk is examples of how
both extrinsic signals, which could be therapy, kind of
similar to what Andreas was talking about.
They could be from the microenvironment, or there could be intrinsic
signals within the cell, such as oncogene activation, and how
that influences this priming. And so we'll start with therapy.
And what Shannon Matulis in the lab did was she took
cells that were resistant to venetoclax here, and I'll show you why
we call these resistant. Even this one is highly resistant with that
micromolar
killing
curves.
And she asked, "Well, what happens?" Well, she already knew from work that Alejo
Morales had done earlier in the lab that most of these, the reason why they don't
respond to venetoclax is there's no BIM or anything else on BCL2 in those
cells, and so they don't respond. But one of them was a curious one to
us, which was this red one, KMS18, because as you can see in
this Co-IP, there's lots of BIM
bound to BCL2. It's actually where most of it's found.
But as I showed in the cartoon on the earlier slide, when we added venetoclax to
these cells, all of it moves to Mcl1, and the
cells are resistant. And I'll just point out that with this,
Mcl1 proteins go up. This is a protein stability issue,
not a transcriptional effect. And that becomes important later
when we think about some of the types of oncogenic effects that occur during
multiple myelomaSo Shannon wanted to
find what were drugs that could actually increase the priming on these cells, and
she turned to one that we use an awful lot in myeloma is Dexamethasone.
And she found that, and this is just quantitating into two lines what
happens
in the IP level
to the levels of BIM. So you can see Dex increases total BIM and increases the
priming on cells or binding of BIM to Mcl1,
Bcl2, Bcl-x. It doesn't really change the pattern very much.
Venetoclax clearly changes the pattern in both of these because you're releasing
things, and picked up by Mcl1. But the combination of them, you
completely end up releasing enough BIM from Bcl2 such that
you kill the cells. And we show in patient samples that, in fact, this can have
profound effects when you add Dexamethasone, such that all of these resistant
cells, some of these tumors become highly sensitive.
And in fact, Jonathan Koffman translated this to a clinical trial
adding Dexamethasone to Venetoclax in the very early phase one and phase
two, and increased the overall response rates that were seen there.
Another factor that we looked at was stromal components.
And so what Shannon Matulas did in this experiment was she took
myeloma cells that were isolated from patients, and she either did
purified plasma cells or she used them with the
stroma that came out of the bone marrow aspirate, and then treated them with
ABT-737, the Bcl2, Bcl-x inhibitor that Chris
mentioned in his introduction talk.
And in every case, if there was stroma there, the cells became much more resistant
to the drug. And so she then modeled this in cell lines and took
a cell line and showed that, in fact, if you culture cells, co-culture with a
stromal component or condition media from those cells, you made the
cells resistant. And since we knew that the
stromal cells make a lot of IL6 and myeloma cells are responsive to IL6, she then
neutralized that and showed she completely could neutralize this by just blocking
IL6 and IL6 receptor. Vikas Gupta decided to make this a
little more translational, so he did this with Venetoclax and Venetoclax-sensitive
cells and showed the same thing. And then Shannon showed that, in fact, it was the
most important thing in the stroma, because if she knocked out
IL6 from the stromal cells, they no longer protected from the Venetoclax killing.
How does this happen? Well, we thought it would change protein expression, and we
do see a change in
one cell line. Again, the same one I was just talking about, that Mcl1 goes up
when you add IL6. But we don't see any changes actually in any of the
anti-apoptotic proteins
when we looked at this. And then what Vikas did was he actually took cells.
He only treated them for three hours with both
ABT-737 and IL6. So he didn't really give a chance
to induce a lot of protein. And what you can see is that the ABT here could induce
cytochrome C release to 40%, and it was pretty much completely blocked in
this very short period of time, suggesting that these were maybe post-translational
events. And so Becca Owens in the lab has been doing
proteomics on this, and she did the experiment where she treated cells for six
hours. And you can see we don't see a lot of protein changes in these three cell
lines. However, you see a lot of phosphorylation changes.
And when we look at what those are, curious enough in these cells, I'm just
showing two of the lines here. Bcl2l11, so BIM
comes up again as a protein that's phosphorylated during this
process.
And through data I don't have time to show, but it's all published at this
point. What we were able to show is it's also phosphorylated on two sites,
serine 77 and serine 69, and that's a
MEK-dependent fashion, so
downstream of JAK. We do obviously see some Mcl1.
We see it all going up at the message level, but not so much at the protein level.
And that when we treat with IL6, we actually see a shift
of BIM binding from Bcl2 to Mcl1, explaining
resistance to things like ABT-737 and Venetoclax.
So based on this, Vikas Gupta and Jonathan Koffman actually now have a trial going
where they're treating patients, pre-treating with Tocilizumab to block IL6
receptor prior to Venetoclax treatment in
refractory multiple myeloma.
But we're still interested in BIM phosphorylation.
And Jason Konichpoo was a student in the lab, and he was looking at this, and
he only saw at serine 69, where we had an antibody,
this phosphorylation constitutive, and this has a BRAF-activating
mutation, which would be consistent with, again, MEK-driven
events.
But he looked in cell lines, and he used a phospho affinity gel
electrophoresis called Phos-tag, where if you have phosphorylation,
the bands migrate slower. And he could show that all of
these were actually sensitive to lambda phosphatase treatment.
Therefore, these are all due to phosphorylation.
And they were in cells where we didn't have RAF mutations and things like that
as well.
And he actually found this also in patient samples too.
So there's a lot of constitutive phosphorylation going on.
And so we went back into the proteomics data, and what Becca found was that there
were two sites, serine 94 and serine 87, that were being
phosphorylated here. And then we used a second data set that I'm
not showing here from Arun Weida at UCSF and found the same things.
Moreover, recently Jan Cronke had published a paper doing
phosphoproteomes on over 150 patient
samples. And
serine 94 turns out to be one of the most common phosphorylation events that we
found in myeloma. And so we decided to focus on that
initially. And so we made knock-in
mutations of either an alanine or glutamic acid.
And with Venetoclax, we didn't really see anything particularly interesting.
And these are in the cells that-- This was actually JP Dougherty
doing. These are the cells where there was
high phosphorylation. And interestingly enough, when you make the alanine mutant,
you do make the cells more
resistant to the Mcl1 inhibitor
AZD5991.Becca focused on the cell that
didn't have phosphorylation, and she did BH3 profiling, which I
know that Chris will talk more about in his
talk. And so using peptides that bind
promiscuously to the different BCL2 proteins, we
really didn't see any change in priming.
But the one place we did see it was this HRK peptide.
This is the one that binds BCL-X, where there was no priming of BCL-X, and
now they're highly primed, suggesting
that phosphorylation here in these cells could
result in a more BCL-X dependency in this cell, and an
opportunity, potentially, for co-targeting here.
And then what I want to finish off with in the last few minutes
is another case of an
intrinsic change, and that was this 11;14
translocation. This is found in about 15% to 20% of myeloma patients.
It results in juxtaposition of cyclin D1 to the IgH
enhancer, so high expression of cyclin D1.
And pre-clinical data from Martine Amiel suggested that these patients may be
more sensitive to venetoclax. However, the
original venetoclax trial didn't actually take heed
to that and just treated all patients.
And what you can see is they had a 21% overall response rate.
But
some people just decided to only put 11;14 patients on it because
40% of those patients responded,
while only 6% of the patients who didn't have it.
And so there was something intrinsic about this.
We were actually looking at this in patient samples.
This is about 70 overall. And we were able to mimic this just by doing
ex vivo treatment for 24 hours, where about half of our
11;14s were below this 100 nanomolar IC50,
where only about 10% of the non-11;14 samples were.
So we wanted to understand this a little bit more.
And so what
Vikas did was he actually took 31 cell lines and
treated them with venetoclax, generated dose curves.
And sure enough, just like the patient samples and just like the patients, about
half of the 11;14s were sensitive,
where only 10% of the non-11;14s were.
And you could see differences in RNA-seq in BCL2 expression
and MCL1. And you can look at these
ratios, but these differences were not, for the most part, big enough to actually
see a difference where you could predict a patient was going to be sensitive or
resistant. It's just statistically, as a group, there was this difference.
And so he wanted to look further, and so he
looked at all differentially expressed genes between sensitive and resistant
in cell lines as well as in patient samples.
And there was a lot of overlap here because he took a meta
gene set of these upregulated genes.
They were highly enriched in the patient samples.
And this just shows a map of all of them, and anything that was black
was significant in at least one of either the patient samples or the
cell lines. The ones in red are the only ones that were actually
overlapping significance in both.
And none of those actually say BCL2 or anything like that on
it. We didn't see any changes there, and that's because the mRNA level, we actually
don't see any differences in BCL2, MCL1, or
BCL-X expression in these patient samples.
So what is different? And what was different was that while these are plasma cells,
they actually expressed genes that were more consistent with B cells.
So
CD20, CD79A,
PAX5, and suggesting that they have a slightly altered
differentiation,
and that maybe it's the differentiation state that's actually helping set this.
We also, at this time, when I showed you this earlier about all these
samples we tested, 16 of these patients were actually treated with venetoclax,
and this ex vivo test actually predicted which ones would
respond or not.
If the IC50 was below 100 nanomolar, those patients pretty
much all responded. If it didn't,
they didn't respond.
Vikas actually extended this to a larger group cohort, found that it still held
that the
overall response rate in sensitive patients was close to 90%, where it was only
about half here. Part of the reason we started seeing some of these respond was
because of dexamethasone was added to more of these patients.
And that resulted in an overall
better outcome by PFS and a strong biomarker
score by receiver operator characteristic curve.
The other thing it did is it was really interesting that we had pre- and
post-treatment samples. And you can see in every one of them, the post-treatment
sample was more resistant. Even those which we would have called sensitive were
seven times more resistant than these.
But the one I'm going to really point to is the worst one here,
MM91, which had a huge change pre- and post.
And so this was a patient of a colleague, Nizar Bahloul.
And what Nizar found was
he did single-cell CNV on this, thinking that maybe MCL1 was going to
be changed and altered, and we did not see any changes in MCL1.
And in fact, we treated that patient sample with the MCL1 inhibitor, and
it was the most resistant we'd ever seen.
What this patient had acquired was another of these BCL2 mutations,
similar to what Andreas had mentioned early in his talk, and this was one that
hadn't been characterized. We showed that, in fact, if you put this into
cells, just like the G101V in the original CLL
studies, it decreased the priming, particularly
from the bad peptides shown in BCL2.
The cells become very resistant, and very much like the
G101V, it's still a functional BCL2.
It binds Bim, but now the drug can no longer
release the Bim from
BCL2. Finally, I just want to show another example that
we just recently published, where we worked with several groups at the Mayo Clinic,
in Ostrava, and Memorial Sloan Kettering, and took all of our patients together
who had been treated with venetoclax.
And what we determined was patients who had RAS-activating mutations
did worse. They had worse-Responses and did worse
overall, very similar to what happens with the 1q gain.
1q is where Mcl1 is, so that's another thing that can drive some of this
resistance. And so we modeled this
in cell lines by overexpressing either wild type or the
activated Ras, and you only get an advantage with the activated Ras.
And the activated Ras also is the only thing that also causes a change
and lowers the overall priming on BCL2.
So with that, I just want to conclude by saying that mitochondrial priming can be
enhanced by therapy, providing the basis for the effective combination
approaches when targeting apoptosis.
The priming is inhibited by extrinsic factors such as stroma or cytokine
factors, and this mechanism seems to be both transcriptional and
post-translational regulation of BCL2 proteins, including
regulation of Bim, which can also occur in an intrinsic fashion because we see it
very constitutively in these cells.
The 11;14 translocation, I should say there, sorry
about that, is associated with BCL2 dependence and venetoclax sensitivity, and it
seems to be related to an altered differentiation.
And then finally, both extrinsic and intrinsic factors can actually
overcome this type of resistance.
So with that, I'd like to thank you, and happy to take any questions.
I'll start with a question. I'm curious, have you looked at what
changes are being caused by the Ras activation that then feed
into this venetoclax resistance?
Yeah. So that's what we're looking at.
And so from AML, there's been studies that
suggest it's actually inducing Mcl1.
Mm-hmm.
We don't see that, and in fact, in those cells that I showed at the end, where we
had put the different Ras, the wild type or the activated
in,
we clearly see resistance to venetoclax.
We see almost no change to the Mcl1 inhibitor.
If anything, maybe a slight resistance to that.
And we didn't see anything in the priming.
So we don't think it's the change in Mcl1.
And that kind of leads us back to other potential
post-translational modification events.
And one of the ones we're actually thinking about a lot right now is BAD, because
it can be phosphorylated in that pathway as well.
Yeah. It gets complicated.
Hi. Great talk. I just have two question.
So first is, I saw you combine with the
BCL-xL with the BCL2, but
does Mcl will complementary? Have you tested
just combine the Mcl plus the BCL-xL
to test it the treatment?
Yeah, that's first.
Okay, first one. So, first one, no.
So
clearly,
in I think everything we ever tested, and we did it in patient samples too.
When you combine a BCL2 inhibitor and an Mcl1 inhibitor, it's lights out.
It just wipes out everything. I'm not sure about how feasible that is because of
toxicity issues, but it really works.
We didn't do much when we combined with a BCL-xL inhibitor, in part because I don't
think we had very potent BCL-xL inhibitors to work with.
The PROTAC actually is a pretty good one, and we've not gone back to revisit it.
But I'd also be a little concerned about some of the potential toxicities.
And David can comment on this. I don't think he thinks
ABT-737 really inhibits BCL-xL at all, or very little, if I remember right.
Yeah. Currently, I designed the siRNA, just combined
both this one. We are exciting to find the 80%
of the AML cell just die,
apoptosis. So very interesting that we just combined those two
siRNA to test it.
Yeah, they clearly work, and in fact, actually, BCL2 and Mcl1
inhibitors were tested clinically
in AML, and they ended up having to stop it because of
toxicity.
And also, they have heart
toxicity. Is there any some drug can
develop this conditional, the release this drug, just
avoiding to this heart disease toxicity?
Yeah. So to avoid the heart-- So could you target the Mcl1
inhibitor
to the tumor cells? It's an interesting idea.
The question would be, can you get enough into the tumors that way?
But I think because of the cardiotoxicity, that's probably something that
people, I'm sure, are actively working on.
Thank you.
I was intrigued by your dexamethasone data.
How does that work?
So
I never actually understood why dexamethasone worked at anywhere, and I asked the
guy who ran our phase one clinic this one time, and I said, "Why do we put
dexamethasone in everything?" And he said, "Because dexamethasone is like bacon.
It goes well with everything." And I think the reason why he was right is it
induces Bim,
and because it induces Bim, it just increases your priming.
And it did it really across the board, but by having more
BCL2 priming alone, that seemed to be sufficient to
have enough release that you could actually kill the cell.
But is it known how it increases Bim?
It's transcriptional.
But through which pathway?
Which?
Which pathway is activated? Or is it dexamethasone directly?
It's the glucocorticoid receptor.
Is it directly?
Yeah.
Okay.
Thank you.
Sure.
Very nice talk. Congratulations.
I would like to make a comment on Mcl1 and cardiotox, because it
comes up in every single talk. To the best of my knowledge, there's never
been clinical cardiotoxicity observed in the Mcl1
trials. No drop in ejection fraction, no catastrophic
congestive heart failure. So that happens when you do it
in a mouse. You do a complete knockout of Mcl1, which is
different from inhibiting Mcl1, and then you get cardiac failure.
But in patients, to my knowledge, was never been observed.
I just want to make that clear.
No, I think that's correct with all of them.
But I think what was being observed was you were seeing
proteins in the blood that were spiking and going up.
So while they had not become-Then I had a clinical event
that was clearly evidence of cardiotoxicity based on
release of cardioprotections measured in the blood.
So this spike in these "cardiac proteins"
comes from the
spleen. So when you have massive lysis of leukemic cells,
the
kidney is secreting this.
And so it's not necessarily cardiac.
But clinically, again, there was never any cardiac.
But I think it scared the companies enough to just stop it because of the history
of the genetics that Joe Offerman had showed years earlier to
say that it would be there.
May I ask a question?
Yes.
A really nice talk.
I have a really general question regarding BCL2 biology, and whether,
have you ever tested integrated stresses
have played a role in the BCL2
protein stability?
I'm sorry, which?
The integrated stresses condition.
Yeah, such as ER stress, something like that.
Yeah. So, those pathways can induce things like Noxa
and
I think Puma, and I think Bim also gets induced by that as
well. So those pathways definitely induce that.
In the case of Noxa, Noxa can recruit one of the E3
ligases there. And in fact, the reason why Bim probably
stabilizes MCL1, in fact, and the MCL1 inhibitors stabilize
MCL1, is you end up blocking the ability to recruit
the E3 ligase
through that Noxa protein.
Okay. Thank you.
Yeah. Great. Let's thank Larry.
Okay, great.
Well, I'm very honored to have the final talk of today's
session. We're going to change our focus a little bit from heme malignancies
to solid tumors, and I'm going to take you through a couple of stories about how
we believe we can potentially enhance therapy
outcomes for solid tumors by targeting the same apoptosis pathway.
These are my disclosures.
So a lot of what I'll show you today has to do with ovarian
cancer, but it's actually broadly applicable to a wide range of different
solid cancers. And I'll really show you at the very end data across a
wide variety of solid cancer cell lines and other models
that we've used to then validate some of the things that I'll show you here.
But I will focus on ovarian cancer. It's actually a fascinating disease.
Typically diagnosed at an advanced stage, high disease
burden. Pretty poor outcomes overall.
About 20% of patients are cured with the cytotoxic chemotherapy that we
administer, with 80% of patients relapsing.
The period of treatment response is quite variable from patient to
patient. But typically, with every stage of treatment,
there's less and less period of response, and a
less likelihood of potential cure.
So what do we actually treat ovarian cancer with?
Well, it's cytotoxic drugs, paclitaxel and carboplatin.
So carboplatin is a DNA-damaging alkylating agent, and
paclitaxel is a microtubule hyperstabilizer.
Now these drugs, platinum agents and paclitaxel, are widely used in other
solid cancers, which we think is part of the reason why some of
the things that I'm going to show you are actually applicable to other solid
tumors. Importantly, both of these therapies are known to
produce high levels of proapoptotic signals in cancer
cells. So whether the cells are going to die or not via the apoptosis
pathway is a side question, but we do know that we are producing a lot of
apoptotic signaling in response to these treatments.
So we wanted to know whether potentially enhancing the ability for those
apoptotic signals to actually trigger apoptotic cell death could be
an interesting and efficacious treatment for ovarian
cancer and other solid tumors. Now, our lab uses a lot of BH3
profiling.
Larry already introduced this assay to some extent, and I won't go into the
details of it. It was actually something developed by the current NCI director,
Tony Letai. But the basic premise is that we're taking cells and
exposing their mitochondria to proapoptotic signals in the form of these
BH3 peptides. And they mimic the activity of proapoptotic
proteins such as Bim and Bid. We've talked about those here today.
And so we're essentially able to titrate in death doses and then
determine or watch for the release of cytochrome C from
mitochondria, which shows that the cells have committed themselves to apoptotic
cell death. That allows us to measure something called apoptotic priming, or
the cell's proximity to the apoptotic threshold, which we found
multiple times is really important for how cells are going to respond to different
types of therapies.
We also can use this assay to do something a little bit different, which is to
measure apoptotic dependencies.
So these are cellular dependencies on pro-survival proteins, such as the ones that
have been described today. And we do this by using
BH3 peptides derived from other proteins such as
Bad, HRK, Ms1 or MCL1,
Noxa. And this allows us to not only
identify
how primed cells are, but actually what proteins we need to target in order
to drive cell death or drive apoptosis in those cells.
And that's important because we actually now have developed BH3 mimetics
that target many of these proteins, and they're available clinically.
So I've shown a few here.
ABT-199, venetoclax, is a very potent BCL2 inhibitor,
FDA approved for use in CLL and AML and a few
other heme malignancies. But we also have ones that are targeting
BCL-XL, including navitoclax that targets BCL2 and BCL-XL.
This was actually the first BCL2/BCL-XL inhibitor to make it to the clinic.
Unfortunately, also causes that thrombocytopenia that we've talked about that would
be part of the focus of today's talk.We also have
very specific MCL-1 inhibitors such as S63845.
This is a drug made by Servier. A very, very good MCL-1 inhibitor,
does have some of these cardiac troponin signals that Larry was just talking about.
So it's been slow going clinically with those agents.
And then finally, we have drugs that target BCL-XL specifically, which is really
going to be the focus of what I'm going to talk about.
And these include the original drug, WEHI539, but then also
next generation inhibitors that are very potent, like
A-1331852, and then a BCL-XL
PROTAC degrader DT2216, which we find to be a very
effective, very exciting molecule that is now in clinical trials.
So we use BH3 profiling to look for these dependencies, and
then translate those or then test and validate those with some of these
BH3 medics that we know have clinical relevance.
So in ovarian cancer specifically, we first started out with just a very
basic study using high-grade serous ovarian carcinoma cell lines,
and we tested their overall apoptotic priming with this BH3 profiling
assay. And what we found is uniformly across these cell lines, they did
respond to these proapoptotic signals with release of cytochrome C,
indicating that the apoptosis pathway is alive and well in these ovarian cancer
cell lines. We also tested their sensitivity to
BCL-XL specific or MCL-1 specific or
BCL-2
dependent-- tested for the dependencies on those pro-survival proteins.
And the most consistent thing we found was that they do express or do
exhibit BCL-XL dependence, as indicated by the response to the
HRK peptide here.
They did not show much sensitivity to the MCL-1 inhibition,
and I'll show you in a subsequent slide that this is also not reflecting any
BCL-2 inhibition or dependence. We took a step back and also
looked at DepMap data to look at expression of BCL-2
family proteins as well as dependencies.
We see that in ovarian cancer, there's actually extremely low levels of
BCL-2. And we've talked a lot about BCL-2 because it's a very relevant
protein for targeting of heme malignancies.
It turns out in solid cancers, it's kind of hit or miss.
It's expressed in some but not others.
And in ovarian cancer, one of the reasons that BCL-XL turns out to be such a great
target is because BCL-2 is very low.
So you don't have to deal with this additional pro-survival protein that's
buffering against cell death. We see that BCL-XL encoded by
BCL2L1 is very highly expressed in ovarian cancer cell lines, and
MCL-1 is highly expressed as well with lower levels of BCL-W.
When we actually knock these out via CRISPR or in the
DepMap database, when these are knocked out via CRISPR, we see that really only
BCL-XL is a pretty uniformly
essential gene in these ovarian cancer cell lines.
This is 50 some cell lines,
indicating that this is probably the strongest of all the pro-survival proteins in
ovarian cancers. There's some mild dependence on MCL-1 seen here.
However, when we actually treat these cells with BCL-XL inhibitors
or
MCL-1 inhibitors, we see that there
is some degree of apoptosis induced, but it's fairly mild.
And that's
due to the fact that these cells actually undergo pretty rapid apoptotic
adaptation, where they're upregulating other pro-survival proteins to help them
survive. And so we knew that we had to actually combine the BCL-XL
inhibition with other agents in order to then fully
drive significant amounts of cell death.
So utilizing our panel of high-grade serous ovarian
carcinoma cell lines, we combined BCL-XL inhibitors or
BCL-2 or MCL-1 inhibitors with standard of care agents.
And what I'm showing you here is just the responses to the agents alone on the
left versus in combination with paclitaxel.
And paclitaxel was synergistic in the vast majority of these
high-grade serous ovarian carcinoma cell lines.
We saw this was also true when we looked at colony formation assays.
Anytime we inhibit BCL-XL in combination with paclitaxel, we
see very potent induction of cell death and elimination of
colony outgrowth. This was not true at all for BCL-2 inhibition or
MCL-1. And interestingly, when we inhibit BCL-XL and
MCL-1 together, we eradicate the colonies
completely,
and that's irrespective of whether the paclitaxel is actually there or not,
indicating that the co-targeting of MCL-1 and BCL-XL is going to be the
most effective way forward.
When we looked at actually patient specimens, we wanted to see whether there was
also indications of potential BCL-XL or other types of dependence
in high-grade serous ovarian carcinoma.
And interestingly, we did see that regardless of whether the patient
specimens were
from patients that were treatment naive or those that had received prior therapy
or neoadjuvant, we did see indications of BCL-XL dependence in these
patient tumors, indicating that this is not something restricted to just cell
lines.
Now, the targeting of BCL-XL for ovarian cancer therapy isn't a totally new idea.
This has been around for quite a few years.
But as we've been talking about throughout this session, there
is an on-target toxicity that we've had to kind of be
challenged with over the years, and that's the on-target thrombocytopenia caused by
BCL-XL inhibitors. As it turns out, platelets express
BCL-XL and are highly dependent on it.
So as soon as you dose animals or humans with
BCL-XL inhibitors, you see this very rapid platelet drop even within just a
few hours.
So we needed to come up with a way to overcome this.
In one side project, we actually looked at BCL-XL dependence in
human platelets and found that there's actually a difference between
platelets that are newly formed versus those that have been in circulation for
quite some time. We see that young platelets actually exhibit
lower level of apoptotic priming and also lower dependence
on BCL-XL. We took advantage of this in a mouse
model by treating mice with romiplostim, Nplate.
It's a thrombopoietin agonist, stimulating platelet production, and then
challenging the mice with navitoclax, that conventional BCL-XL
inhibitorWe saw that although we definitely still
induced apoptosis in a wide range of these platelets, the
platelet levels never reached those levels that would be considered to be below
normal in this mouse model, indicating that this may also be an effective
strategy for potentially protecting platelets or protecting patients from
BCL-XL-induced thrombocytopenia.
However, another strategy was developed by a collaborator of ours,
Dao-Hong Zhao, who came up with a really interesting idea to make
ABT-263 navitoclax into a PROTAC degrader
of BCL-XL instead of an inhibitor.
And that was done by taking the ABT-263 drug and linking it to an
E3 ligase ligand. So this would essentially trigger the
degradation of BCL-XL instead of its just simple
inhibition. This was very effective at degrading
BCL-XL in nucleated cells, but interestingly, platelets express very
low levels of VHL, and so they don't degrade BCL-XL in the same manner
and are actually largely protected from this agent.
In our hands, when we treat ovarian cancer cells with this degrader, we
see a very impressive potent downregulation of
BCL-XL. Within a few hours, we already start to see the
protein levels of this BCL-XL dwindling, and it's almost
completely gone across every cell line we've tested by 24 hours.
When we combine this with paclitaxel, we see something kind of interesting
happening, which is that the degrader consistently leads to
loss of BCL-XL across all of our models tested, shown here.
This is even just a low level of the degrader.
But when we combine this with paclitaxel, we see that paclitaxel leads to a
decrease in MCL1 levels. Across every cell line that we've
tested, for the vast majority of the cell lines tested, we see
this degradation of MCL1 occurring.
And then in the combination treatment, we see essentially the elimination of both
BCL-XL and MCL1, which we think is then driving this
synergistic apoptosis in those cells.
We wanted to look at this a little bit more formally.
So we utilized
a strategy to separate out the mitotically arrested versus
non-mitotically arrested cells in response to paclitaxel and then performed
BH3 profiling. We found that those that were arrested in
mitosis by paclitaxel treatment had a massive spike in their
apoptotic priming and also had a large increase in their
BCL-XL dependence.
Molecularly, what was happening in these cells is that those that were arrested in
mitosis had a dramatic downregulation of MCL1 levels.
This is a very short half-life protein, and so its levels are
regulated largely by active transcription of additional
mRNAs. And so as soon as cells paused in
mitosis essentially are unable to keep up the levels of MCL1, and it
drops quite dramatically. When we look at the actual interactions
between these proteins during the course of treatment, we see that normally
BCL-XL is actively sequestering Bim, Bak, and Bax in untreated
cells, keeping those proapoptotic molecules from inducing apoptosis.
When we give the degrader, we essentially are able to free those
proapoptotic proteins, and then in combination with the
paclitaxel, which then frees the proteins from the MCL1 that's
normally there to buffer against cell death, and then we get full-on
induction of apoptosis. And we can see that the converse is true
when we immunoprecipitate MCL1 and look for the reciprocal binding
interactions.
So now we wanted to test whether this was actually going to be effective in vivo.
So we utilized several different cell line and patient-derived
xenograft models. I'll show you the data from probably one of the most exciting
ones, which is DF83. This is a PDX model developed
at Dana-Farber Cancer Institute by Joyce Liu from a patient that
had four prior lines of chemotherapy treatment.
P53 mutant is known very well as a chemo-resistant
model of ovarian cancer.
At first, when we just utilized flank xenograft models for this,
we saw that true to form, these cells were very resistant
to paclitaxel treatment, also very resistant to the single agent
DT 2216 treatment. However, the combination therapy was able
to completely eradicate these tumors, and there was no evidence of tumor
regrowth even after cessation of therapy.
Interestingly, those that were treated with the DT 2216 showed evidence of
upregulation of MCL1 and BCL2 to drive this resistance
to the single-agent treatment, as we had expected based on that apoptotic
adaptation. We saw that there was a transient drop in
platelet levels in animals dosed with DT 2216,
consistent with the fact that it has the ABT-263 drug
as part of its core. But then as we are taking advantage of
this PROTAC-based activity, we see that the platelet levels were
maintained in safe levels for the duration of the experiment.
We didn't see any effects on white blood cell counts nor any
other toxicities.
This of course, led to a massive, very impressive increase in
overall survival.
When we looked in a separate cohort of mice and looked for evidence of
changes
in immunofluorescent staining of these tumor sections, we saw that
paclitaxel led to actually somewhat of an increase in BCL-XL
expression in these DF83 tumors.
Interestingly, some of the BCL-XLs seem to be actually even in the
nucleus. In the presence of the DT 2216, though, here in
green, we saw that there was a very
satisfying decrease in BCL-XL
expression in these tumors, regardless of whether paclitaxel was on board or not.
We also utilized an orthotopic model or
intraperitoneal model
where this is more mimicking the activity and the growth
of ovarian cancer in vivo, which frequently grows as ascites in the abdomen of
patients. And we saw that when we combined the paclitaxel and
DT 2216 treatment in this model, we saw that there was a very
impressive reduction in tumor burden getting down to just the background
level of luminescence that the assay would allow.
And there was a very nice extension of overall survival.
This was again tolerated very well with the platelet levels remaining quite
high.We didn't see any evidence of toxicities
in any of the tissues that we looked at, including the spleen, the lung, liver,
kidney, and heart, which was consistent with the very good
tolerability by the mice.
So this has led us to launch a clinical trial at Dana-Farber Cancer Institute,
testing the activity of DT 2216 in combination with
paclitaxel in platinum-resistant ovarian cancer in
collaboration with our clinical collaborator, Elizabeth Stover.
We're very excited about this. We have dosed, thus far, three patients,
and are excited to share data and updates with you in the coming several
months.
I want to highlight one thing, though, which is the applicability of some of
these findings across other cancers.
As part of this study, Xing Pang, who is a post-doc in the lab, has
been championing a lot of this work himself.
He tested the sensitivity of about 150 different cancer
cell lines to different types of BH3 mimetics, targeting BCL-XL,
BCL-2, or MCL-1 in order to gauge or
essentially characterize whether different cancer types would have
these types of dependencies. And in heme malignancies, shown here as
DLBCL and myeloma, we see what
we would
assume or think based on the literature, which is that there are some dependencies
on MCL-1, for example, in multiple myeloma, and in
AML, we see some dependence on BCL-2.
However, in solid cancers, there's only mild dependencies, and they're
really restricted, for the most part, to BCL-XL.
But what was interesting as part of this is he also did combination treatments of
all these mimetics together. And what was quite dramatic is that there was
no cancer cell line or very, very few that could withstand
combination treatment with BCL-XL plus MCL-1 inhibition.
This was effective even in the toughest to treat glioblastoma cell lines, as
shown here.
This is not clinically that relevant because of the fact that we
can't target BCL-XL and MCL-1 at the same time,
especially with BH3 mimetics. In other studies done by Johan Spets in my lab a
few years ago, he showed that when we dose animals with BCL-XL plus
MCL-1 inhibitors, we actually see a very strong toxicity in the
vasculature, which then leads to the mice succumbing to this
treatment pretty rapidly.
And this happens really in combination with the BCL-XL and
MCL-1 inhibitor together.
So really,
what this tells us is that we're really getting excellent synergy from the
targeting of MCL-1 plus BCL-XL in these ovarian cancer cells, but the
MCL-1 targeting has to be indirect.
And as we see here, when we ran a panel of different chemotherapeutic agents
and their effect on MCL-1 levels in ovarian cancer cells, we see
really that only paclitaxel was able to deplete MCL-1 levels.
And so we believe that is what's giving us this really excellent
synergistic cell death in combination with the BCL-XL
degrader. And just to also highlight the
fact that this is not restricted to ovarian cancer, we see that when we
test the sensitivity of DT 2216 plus paclitaxel
across a range of solid cancer cell types, both P53 mutant and
wild type, we see excellent evidence of synergy across these.
And finally, interestingly, we see that this is not just
restricted to paclitaxel or microtubule targeting agents.
We see that any agent that is able to induce mitotic arrest synergizes very
well with BCL-XL degradation. So we think that this is also an
exciting avenue for potentially targeting,
or enhancing the activity of aurora kinase inhibitors and polo kinase inhibitors.
And in fact, when we look at combination therapies with BCL-XL
inhibition in solid cancers, including breast cancer, colon, and pancreas,
we see that mitosis-targeting agents are by far the most effective and give you
the highest percentages of synergy.
That being said, there are other agents that also would combine well with BCL-XL
inhibition, and we feel like this is going to be an exciting avenue going forward.
So just to give you a quick one-line summary, really targeting
BCL-XL synergizes with agents that trigger mitotic arrest, including
microtubule targeting drugs or kinase inhibitors, polo kinase inhibitors.
We think that this could be widely utilized to enhance therapy
outcomes for patients with ovarian cancer and other solid tumors.
With that, I just want to thank the people in my lab that did this work and our
excellent collaborators, especially Elizabeth Stover, who's been championing the
patient clinical trial data and clinical trial
execution so well. And I just want to also highlight Xing Pang,
who has done the lion's share of this work. Thank you so much for your time.
Absolutely stunning work. Congratulations.
The combination with
mitotic drugs like PLK1,
PLK4, aurora kinases, may have a different mechanism.
So what we see is induction of polyploidization and followed
by mitotic catastrophe. So I think the cells cannot maintain
growth at these high ploidy levels.
And then, of course, if you also push them into
apoptosis, they will become very sensitive.
But that would be a mechanism to consider when you combine,
let's say, PLK1 inhibitors and BCL-XL
degraders.
Yeah, I think it's an excellent point, and I didn't talk about it here,
but one of the other mechanisms that,
speaking of your aneuploidy, another thing that we see happening is the
acquisition of a senescent state in cells in response to paclitaxel, and I
think that also happens with aurora kinase inhibitors and polo kinase inhibitors.
So we see that those cells are profoundly sensitive to BCL-XL
inhibition as well. And so we think that there's multiple cell states
being induced by these therapies that then can be
exploited by the BCL-XL inhibition to drive potent cell death.
But it's an excellent point.
So BCL-XL induces senescence,
of course. But what I learned from another institution is that
Polyploidization may be a very good target for
particular MP53 mutant leukemias.
So we have PLK4 inhibition, and we have high
sensitivity of P53 mutant leukemias in that case.
So that's something to consider for P53 mutant ones. Mm-hmm.
Absolutely. And in our studies, we've seen that P53 mutant
cell lines certainly are just as sensitive, and in certain cases even more
sensitive than P53 wild type cells to these agents.
I was just wondering if you've tried the DT
2261 in combination with carboplatin
or triple combination, and also its PARP inhibitors, and
how those compare.
Yeah, that's a great point. So, a reviewer of this paper asked us that same
question, so maybe that was you, I don't know.
But
it's actually kind of interesting because we thought in all the studies that we had
done, we saw this molecular mechanism driving the synergy
between the paclitaxel and the BCL-XL degrader.
And so we definitely went in that direction because of that
synergy. But we went back and did those same exact experiments with
carboplatin, and we see, although there's not as much synergy with carboplatin
plus a BCL-XL degrader, there was definitely still evidence of synergy.
And quite interestingly, when we did the triple combination, what's
known to the ovarian cancer field is that actually paclitaxel and carboplatin have
some antagonism because of the fact that carboplatin can drive cell
cycle arrest and reduces the sensitivity of cells to
paclitaxel. And so we see that, this antagonism between those agents.
And when we have DT 2216 on board, it's actually able to
enhance that sensitivity. So in the long term, we feel like
the best avenue forward would be to get this into frontline
treatment with carboplatin and paclitaxel if
possible. But we're taking it one step at a time, so we have to do the
paclitaxel treatments first. But yeah, great question, something that we're really
interested in.
Great, and then also PARP inhibitors. Sorry, that was last.
Oh, yeah. That was your other question. Thanks.
Yeah, so that was one of the first things that we looked at, was PARP
inhibition and BCL-XL degradation simply because we
thought that there's some signals for toxicities with paclitaxel and
carboplatin to try to avoid. And we did not see a very high
level of synergy with PARP inhibitors and BCL-XL degraders.
That being said, we only tested a few models, and so I feel like
there is an opportunity to go back and look a little more deeply at that to see if
we potentially missed something.
Thank you.
Great question.
Hi. Masha Porovski, PMV Pharma.
It's really heartening to see potential paths for these in solid tumors for
targeting these pathways. But I'm wondering if
the changing landscape in ovarian cancer is influencing
how you're viewing these combinations and the
emergence and moving into frontline of
ADCs,
whether or not there's a path there for the
BCL-XL
inhibition.
Yeah, it's such a great point. And it's interesting that
carboplatin and paclitaxel really have been mainstays of ovarian cancer therapy
for decades. Very little movement therapeutically, but more recently there have
been some exciting approvals and some movement on
that. We are thinking about that. We know
that at least the way that we had set it up, we wanted to first look at
this, again, this synergistic induction of cell death with the paclitaxel
plus DT 2216, and we know that the weekly
paclitaxel is a second-line or third-line treatment for these
patients. So we're starting out there.
But certainly if we can make some progress there, then we imagine that this would
actually combine very well with some of these ADCs, where the
payload frequently is a microtubule targeting agent as well.
And so we feel like it's going to lead to that depletion of MCL-1 and potentially a
synergistic cell death. So it is something we're thinking about a lot.
That's a good point.
Excellent work, Chris. Fantastic.
It was only possible because you had the BCL-XL inhibitor
hooked up to be degraded by VHL. Now, couldn't you do the
same with the MCL-1 inhibitor and thereby also gain
independence of the toxicity that you claim that that's why you
cannot combine it with the MCL-1 inhibition directly?
So that's a great point. However, the
issue with the combination of the BCL-XL plus MCL-1
inhibition is really in the vasculature.
And so you would need to have some kind of degrader that didn't degrade BCL-XL in
the vasculature. We do think that BCL-XL is getting degraded in the vasculature.
Mm-hmm.
It's just that it's not dying the same way when you combine the
direct inhibitor because of the fact that paclitaxel only targets
cycling cells, and so that MCL-1 downregulation isn't happening in the
vasculature, which is non-cycling. It's mostly quiescent.
There's some degree of proliferation, but it's very small.
So we think that's where the therapeutic index really comes from.
Now, can we design an MCL-1 degrader that would allow us to
avoid the cardiotoxicity that we've been talking about here today?
I think there are interesting opportunities.
In fact, someone told me before the session that they have developed a
degrader for MCL-1 that might be sparing the
cardiomyocytes to some extent. So I think that that is really an
interesting avenue to go down. And I think this degradation, I
didn't have a chance to really talk about it, but you can see it in the manuscript.
There's also inherent advantages to degrading pro-survival
proteins over just simple inhibition, and that's because of the fact
that you're able to first of all get rid of nearly
100% of the protein.
You go deeper.
There's less opportunity. Yeah, there's a deeper response.
There's less opportunities for the cells to rapidly adapt.
And so we see that there's faster acquisition of resistance when we
do a conventional inhibitor versus a degrader.
And so we think that potentially down the road, this would be the most effective
way forward for some of these other proteins, including MCL-1, if we can get there.
So for the MCL-1 degrader, you would need to have an E3 ligase that
works in the ovarian cancer cells but does not work in the endothelium.
Right?
And does not work-
And in the cardio
... in the cardiomyocytes, ideally.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah. That's exactly right. If you know of one,
we can talk after.
If I could comment
on the inhibitors, which are cardiotoxic or not, they do
cause accumulation of MCL-1 for the reasons that you mentioned,
through the decreased degradation.
So we at least see up to eightfold increased levels of
MCL-1 after inhibitors in cardiomyocytes and other cell
types. So this can be also big differentiating
factor versus, let's say, degraders that can cleanly remove
this protein.
Oh, right. Yeah. Absolutely. And yeah, so that is
one of the other things that we saw consistently was that
when we inhibit BCL-XL, BCL-XL itself is going
up in expression. It's getting stabilized, it's accumulating
because you're constantly feeding more BCL-XL mRNAs into the process.
If you're degrading it, you at least take away that one crutch.
And so we think that that's going to be better long term.
Great.
We have a couple of minutes, so I'm sure our panelists would be happy to stay up
here. If there's questions for any of us, we'd be happy to
address them. If not, please come up and chat with us after the session.
We'd love to hear from anybody that has additional questions or interest in this
work. And let's thank the speakers one more time for
this session.
Thank you all for coming.